[Music]
[Music]
hey
oh
hey we're back did you miss us
it's the van halen of podcasting me and
mark bernardin man
welcome back
to fat man beyond i'm kevin smith i'm
mark bernard hey
hey hey kev
how are you sir do you remember
the twenty-first night of september i do
i love what's happening
i always say to you mark body uh
dancing in september
um i wish i was smart enough to early in
my career put a reference to a date
into something so that the internet you
know would
say it later on i mean i guess like we
got easter and mall rats and [ __ ] but i
wish i'd been more strategic i don't
even think
earth wind and fire is being strategic i
don't think they could have predicted
the internet mark they're smart
musicians
gifted but who could have seen the
internet
coming in 1974 like you guys there's
gonna be a whole network of people with
nothing better to do
than grind youtube which will also be a
thing
and pig stuff to date
and once a year you're going to be so
[ __ ] special yeah once a year we're
going to get enough plays on that one
song to buy us all winnebagos
say that you'll remember
what was the song i was singing right
before we went
oh i don't remember [ __ ] it was good too
it was real
because i had september in my head
yeah but it was like i turned on the
light my ring light and i was like [ __ ]
i forget in any event kids welcome back
uh we're here to talk pop culture and
all the news that's uh [ __ ] to print
sorry we've been away for about two
months
i don't know if anybody knows this
i was off making a feature film ladies
and gentlemen i went off and made a
motion picture called clerks 3 where i
saw
mark bernardin not only on set
but every day that i work on the movie
and cut it together there he is and i've
got a first cut together i just showed
it
to jeff anderson came over and brought
his wife barb and uh they watched it and
he knows the movie
and he he loves it man he was hit
it's very it's funny as [ __ ] very
emotional as well
so
you know i i see you all the time even
though we haven't been doing this
i've seen you once in three months
life of an editor is like where it's
like i literally see you every day
and and you know think about you every
day because you're in the [ __ ] flick
and mark's
mark is in the [ __ ] flick kids
ain't like last time when
well it is like last time and as much as
he said [ __ ]
uh but
it ain't like last time in as much as
like you know blink and you'll miss him
you you cannot miss mark in clerk's
three he's got a stopping little cameo
my my my wife is like so did he give you
a lime this time
like nope
talk to ralph garmin man you gotta wait
years to get along
it's like i already got to be in the
guild before i can get a lot
um no it was a good time i had a blast
uh making the movie it was uh
not only was it like oh [ __ ] we made
another clerks like we i get to tell
there there are now new things that
dante and randall say like you know i
know everything they've ever said and
the audience knows everything they've
ever said because we've seen everything
they've ever said now there's all new
[ __ ] that they're saying um so not only
was that wonderful uh and magic to make
but being back in jersey and like going
to highlands my hometown every day to go
hiking and stuff
oh my god you like i i'm never gonna
have a midlife crisis because like i
just i literally got to go back into my
past and i got to work at quick stop
again which was beautiful because it was
the best way to do it like where i don't
really have to work there if i don't
want to back in the day i had to work
there and [ __ ] but i walked into the
store every day we shut down quick stop
for two weeks it was like having my own
playset with living action figures you
know six feet action figures and [ __ ] oh
it was absolute [ __ ] bliss what a
great way
to spend a summer and we started on my
51st birthday and so like what a great
way to start
the 50 first year brian and jeff were
absolute magic uh trevor and uh austin
are absolutely [ __ ] wonderful and
steal the show
jason
is
like perhaps
[Music]
the
deployed
best
as best as he's ever been in any kevin
smith motion picture like
the perfect amount of jane silent bob
and he's every time he hits the screen
he says something funny and
earns his his place up there uh rosario
is
our queen obviously and just
melts the heart melter
um
you know and drops another [ __ ]
performance clinic
um
yeah man it's
i'm happy i'm beyond happy and so i cut
it i've been cutting you know i'm the
editor as well so i was cutting while we
were shooting
but then i got home um like last was it
last monday or something like that
thought i was coming home to a dying dog
thank god marty not dying she's on the
upswing she blind and she's deaf so
she's bumping into furniture and [ __ ]
like that and she's got as i've said
many times she's one of the most
congested [ __ ] animals i've ever met
in my life so when she sneezes it's like
[ __ ] you know john holmes just
[ __ ] argue
[Music]
shooting at her nose
um to borrow from the great bill hicks
so um i thought i was coming home for
you know the
that horrible decision where it's like
let's get her filet mignon because
there's a needle coming and stuff doctor
came over looked at her he's like look
she's blind and she's deaf but you know
she ain't going anywhere you're just
going to be on
clean up duty for walks her back legs
aren't that weak so now we're in that
stage of life with her that i was with
my other three dogs where eventually you
become their back legs and your whole
life becomes about catching them before
they [ __ ] the bed so they don't roll
around in it and you're constantly like
i wake up every hour on the hour to make
sure she hasn't taken a [ __ ] and rolled
in and stuff like that but i'll do that
for a thousand days just to
keep her with us and the doctor you know
was like she wants to be here bro he's
like as long as she's eating and
drinking
that's the sign of life right there he's
going the moment she stops eating and
drinking you let me know but he's like
this dog wants to be alive that's the
thing that you never know right like you
can never
you know it's like i could ask you mark
if i'm like i should put mark to sleep
but let me ask him and you could tell me
he's like my legs don't work so good no
no it's like i've become his back
i'm tired of him [ __ ] all over my
[ __ ] slippers maybe it's time for
mark to go mark mark being a human being
with a voice could be like shouldn't my
wife make that decision you're just my
podcasting pal it's like how did you
slide into this i mean you're in my will
but you're not in first place
the market tell me that he doesn't want
to go the dog cannot the best way you
can
figure that out based on what the vet
said is like if she's still eating and
drinking like she's she's vital and so
you know we have to do a lot of
like i pet her face in a very specific
way so even though she's blind and deaf
like when i come in and pet her she
knows that it's me and stuff so i
thought i was coming home to like the
ultimate misery
instead we got a reprieve and whatnot so
i was balancing
taking care of marty and editing the
rest of the flick and i wanted to go as
slow as i possibly could because
once i edit it is it i've been dreaming
about this [ __ ] seven years man and
once it's edited it's like well there it
is so you know you're caught between
your head and your heart right where
your head is like finish this [ __ ] but
your heart is like no you just want it
to go on forever and ever
so it it finally you know i ran out of
footage to cut and the first cut was
like 148 and then i brought it down to
like 145.
i'm hoping to bring it down further but
i think it's pretty [ __ ] tight now
the last one clerk's 2 is like an hour
and 37 so we're only about eight minutes
above but
where we go in the movie and the
adventure we go on i think warrants the
additional eight minutes that's me
speaking as the filmmaker and i'm sure
between now and the time you all see it
more time will likely come out because
what i do is i get to sit there and
watch it over and over again and tinker
and then i show it to people and if a
lion don't get a laugh then out it goes
i'll be showing people the movie and if
people are like [ __ ] mark bernardin
clip audi [ __ ] ghosts
like a moyle i'll [ __ ] cut the tip of
that dick right off and [ __ ] yeah it's
like listen i mean if he'd had a line
then it might be worth it
he just sits there mugging at the camera
i tried to give him a line but all he
wanted to do was talk about you know
[ __ ] dc's [ __ ] up
hey not here not here this is not the
part we have a whole venue for that
we're doing this hey speaking of which
did you do your
uh zack snyder's justice league black i
did indeed i spent what did that crow
taste like my friend
it tasted like restraint
is what it tasted like um
you know it's four hours of a movie and
you know i found a good hour to talk
about i'm like you know what i like this
i like this i like this this is pretty
cool this is a better change than the
last one this is a good reclamation
project like
it was uh it was
it was fine it was like being on a diet
you know it's like i'm not eating what i
want to eat but it's not the worst thing
ever either
healthy this is a very healthy
perspective yes it's it's it was
cleansing to my soul did you do it in
the bar
um no i did it from the zoo from the zoo
yeah just me and jc just riding the zoom
pony speaking of banff boy where is he
oh banff man
oh
there he is kids jc
uh proprietor of the the scum and
villainy cantina which is wide open
correct
uh yeah we're wide open
we're open uh we're open right now
how's
really look at you multitasking how's it
been going how is a business out there
in the real world i'll tell you
everything's like open and [ __ ] like
that so i don't know what it's like here
i just got back it's good it's busy uh
we've been really busy actually the
weird thing is
we have a lot of kids coming in who
turned 21 during the pandemic when
everything was closed so they come up to
the bar and they're like um
uh
what should i get
the bartender's like what do you like
and they're like we don't know they're
like well try a blue milk and they'll be
like can i have your credit card to open
a tab and they're like what's a tab
you gotta walk them through their first
part so yeah
look at you very interesting
starting these young kids on the road to
alcohol
how wonderful
um that's how sweet though man that the
kids are coming in like i turned 21
during the pandemic this is where i want
to celebrate it man that man it's
heartwarming to me it is although it's
weird that they don't they haven't
already built in their heads their their
first version at a bar like
i would like your finest slippery
nipples sir i too would like a sex on
the
beach ooh one a long island iced tea
perhaps we've we've heard of those three
drinks i've heard of the long island
iced tea the other two were real drinks
as well the other two are real drinks as
well slippery nipple dude
just gets you drunk
these are nerd kids though they're not
you know they're like what drink would
thor have
we're like he has guardian ale and
they're like another
did they crash the glass as well
um you know i'm not spending a lot of
time down there a lot of my stories are
stories i hear from the employees
because i'm with the baby up home that's
true how goes that man the kid must be
like 26 by now right she's uh
using furniture to stand up
which is exciting because she also falls
down and bumps her head all the time and
the only thing i can think of is like
the football player cte
yeah like oh my gosh is she getting she
getting concussions is she gonna be
crazy and by the time she's eight
um but then i figure everybody probably
bumps their head a lot as a kid kids
kids been bumping their heads for
millennia and we've had wars religious
wars you know what there's something to
be said for
checking into this kid and see
um how is it watching
the kid go from like
to ambitious to like i will climb on a
[ __ ] thing and i will stand old man
it's
it is the most bit which i'm sure you
both realize it's the most bittersweet
thing ever because she was such a
fantastic baby she never cried she slept
through the night
so i miss her being that little but now
that she's doing like real life things
like she's gonna say
uh she knows jen and she knows me and
she you say who's that and she'll go
mama mama and dad dad dad
which is
hold on
she may know you but i know you better
right
i mean this [ __ ] kid you know
come on man like i've known you for 10
years man this kid
she's known me for 10 months
yeah you've known me for 10 years so
so she knows you but she don't know
baby come lately
yeah really [ __ ] come see that yeah
it's bittersweet i like her getting
older and and learning it's exciting
like to see her like learn
to
do stuff like oh you're crawling today
and you're doing this um
we uh we took her to the hollywood bowl
to see john williams
and there was uh there was a point
where you know they show the movie clips
up on the screen
and they were doing um
like a godfather tribute
and it's the scene where the car pulls
up to the tollbooth and the whole
hollywood bowl is like
quiet they know what's going to happen
the music dips
and you have
a 10 month old baby just at the top of
her lungs go
uh-oh
everyone around us cracks up in like the
most serious moment of uh the godfather
tribute
why why were they doing a godfather
tribute during a john williams thing
they do
so because john williams is 89
uh
he does
his body of work isn't deep enough
we've got to throw in some we got to pad
it up because he doesn't have a lot of
work yeah uh david newman does the first
half and it's like a tribute to
hollywood
right yeah and then john williams comes
after intermission and plays his
greatest hits
and kids you know if you sit there and
you're not in california and you listen
to jc go like oh we went to the
hollywood bowl and that sounds like wow
how magical how wonderful
like you could do that when you're out
here like it's it's just a thing that
that's available to people
john williams they seem to pull them out
every year and they do one of these big
john williams things yeah they used to
do it i think he only did one night this
year and in previous years he's done
like a weekend
so he's definitely like pulling back but
i mean he was out there having a good
time
didn't spielberg like he was at the last
one i remember that reading that
yeah
that that like you could do a thing
like that that's the you know
it's worth the kids if you're not from
the area we don't make any money off of
this but if you're not from the area
is worth it go out to the hollywood bowl
for any number of the genre things that
they do coming up soon probably is
nightmare before christmas right don't
they always do something for nightmare
they yeah they just had a good little
like nerd brace where for three weekends
they had
john williams the first weekend
they had black panther the second
weekend so they showed the movie and
played the score yeah it was the first
marvel movie they've ever done live live
score to the screen
and so to listen to the la phil like
kick into the marvel like fanfare was
pretty badass um and they brought out
all of these african musicians to come
and do that soundtrack because it's got
a bunch of [ __ ] that like the la fella
said we got oboes we don't got no
talking drums we don't have that [ __ ]
but it was amazing and then they did uh
harry potter and the half blood prince
on the third weekend
what can i yeah we gave away tickets
here on the podcast did we we did
um speaking of
black panther did you [ __ ] see the
what if killmonger saved tony stark i
did yes we need to talk about what if
um we're going to we're going to i i'm
we're so many things to talk about but i
imagine we probably have a sponsor that
we should give a shout out to before we
go anywhere though kids
we're doing the show live at the cantina
when is it mark next tuesday so a week
from today we'll be doing this live in
the cantina um
tickets
are on sale now at what eventbrite you
go to csmod.com or something like that
as well
but you get tickets come watch us live
do it before you know
they [ __ ] lock us back down again
although
two days ago yesterday
i got my booster did you i did
apparently it was open for
people with like you know heart issues
or whatever the [ __ ] so i made my
appointment cvs got the booster man and
fi you know i was a pfizer kid so i got
a pfizer booster and
[ __ ] that stings nice things but it go
right into the muscle and i don't have
any muscle and i got no upper body
strength
so i've been feeling it's like the hip
bone
i think the real question is how are
your friends testicles
yeah not your testicles your testicles
are fine
i've heard that they're they're they're
shriveled up and
it's so weird that well like it really
is something out of ferris bueller where
it's just like you know somebody's
friend's father's sister brother said
that they saw ferris at 31 flavors like
um all right but before we uh dive into
that
before we go dive into the news
let's uh talk about the good folks
at native
kids go to nativedeo.com
right now and follow along
nativedeo.com
fat man if you want to help us out
um
let me ask you this man uh you don't
like stinking do you i don't today was a
stinky day kids i walked around the
reservoir for the first time you were
nice out here it was nice it was a
little scary though because at one point
you're surrounded by fence and i felt
like i was like at the great adventure
safari and then i saw a sign that was
like
don't feed the deer because they attract
bear and [ __ ] mountain lions and i'm
like what the [ __ ] man i just want to
walk so anyway i did seven mile walk
today and i was sweaty as [ __ ] you know
what i [ __ ] needed when i came home
tell me my friend
god i had to go native mark i went into
the shower used every [ __ ] native
product that my wife buys
we don't get this [ __ ] free
buys it man and rightfully so native's
like we pay you to do ads the least you
can do is buy our product
believe me it ain't even me kids my wife
[ __ ] loves the native products so i
got rid of my stink today
thank god to the good folks native made
it so easy uh we've been talking about
these kids forever man
uh they do it right
it's a vegan product forever and sakes
man they got a broad spectrum spf 30
sunscreen for your face and body check
that [ __ ] out i could use that on my
walks because i don't know if you could
see this mark but
i've got here look at look at that look
at the garbage man tan up on my forehead
oh very nice yeah
i had to we included a scene in clerks
three where me and jay are standing
outside and leaning on the wall and i
have one of those
sun [ __ ] reflectors because
i got so much [ __ ] color and stuff
like that so i could use the spf 30
sunscreen for my face and body really
just my face my body is [ __ ] hidden
everything else is like white fish belly
and stuff but right here
george hamilton all the way man
um kids george hamilton was an actor who
liked to tan minutely
uh it's lightweight it absorbs quickly
and you can choose between unscented or
coconut and pineapple come on man you
can smell like a pina colada
while you're walking out under the sun
man native's on a mission to overhaul
your entire hygiene routine by putting
the care
in self-care with products carefully
made to work against odor that are made
with simple ingredients and smell great
so much so you might want to eat them
you get their deodorant body wash in
amazing scents like coconut vanilla
citrus and herbal musk lavender and rose
that's my speed i love lavender and more
man you can even build your own
personalized product bundles mix and
match three of your favorite scents and
keep on rotation so you have something
for every occasion
you want to say a thing or two about
these good folks
i mean all i'm gonna say man it's just
stop [ __ ] stinking don't be it don't
be a don't be a doof
smell like poof
oh [ __ ]
desert a writer write a first draft kids
yeah that's not the finished draft
he's getting started
he got stuck somewhere in the middle
and couldn't pull the chute sometimes
he's got to write something anything
even blows but it just gives you a thing
to go to
puke draft um but yeah so stay fresh
stay fresh and stay clean with native by
going to nativedeo.com fat man or use
the promo code fat man at checkout and
get 20 off your first order that's
nativedeo.com fatman or use promo code
fat man at checkout for 20 off your
first order
we thank the good folks at native who
for whatever reason really do believe in
this show
i mean we've been away for a minute and
still when we come back they were like
no no we're ready to go so
thank you native smart bless the good
folks at native man they keep us
smelling good
indeed
um all right let's let's let's talk
again yeah we we got a couple of like
high level things to talk about um and
then we got some news to get into all
right let's do the high level which was
the emmys were last night mark and i
didn't
i didn't watch um not because i'm cool
or anything i just i was doing other
[ __ ]
but
i kept an ear because you know i i got
no skin in the game i got no show of my
own in the horse and the race so to
speak however
there are shows that i've enjoyed over
the year and uh and i was very happy to
see a number of genre shows that i
particularly care about
up for major awards couldn't believe and
was so delighted that the emmy you know
the television academy embraced
mandalorian embraced
juan division uh embraced
um uh lovecraft country like you know
like it just felt like right on they get
it like
this is gonna be the year
so i
assumed
that juan division i didn't think it
would sweep but i honestly did feel like
you know elizabeth olsen was a strong
candidate you know i know she was going
to be up against mayor of east town and
whatnot and she's wonderful as well but
strong candidate to win you know
uh catherine hahn is that her name
katherine
uh you know i thought it was a shoe-in
you know paul bettany i thought was more
iffy but not because he's not a good
actor or anything like that he had
competition in his category and stuff
and you know she had the the wonderful
grief stricken showy part which had
[ __ ] emmy bait written all over it so
you know before you know they did
technical ceremony a few days ago and
one division picked up some tin and i
was like right on it's beginning here
comes the sweep
and
nothing
i think everybody ran into the crown
um maravee's town
and uh
yeah there was just this weird and and
queen's gambit
was like the weird three-pronged um
cooler that got deployed on every
everybody's hopes and dreams stiff
competition to be fair
indeed you know it's not like oh they
were robbed you're talking about some
pretty quality shows
one but like hey
yeah and the thing that the emmys never
seems to do still seems to be a bias
though against genre stuff
there's a bias against lots of stuff at
the emmys
oh well mark i i i don't know what
you're talking about i'm just talking
about my
comic book [ __ ] i like don't get picked
that's unfair whatever issues you have
mark that's your own petty nonsense
yeah that was another [ __ ]
like it was it reminded me of the
you had a wonderful chance to honor an
entire body of work
with a man who just passed with michael
k williams and honor him for
not just you know the work he just
recently did but omar and the wire work
and it was it reminded me of like
remember the oscar race where chadwick
bozeman had passed away and like a great
opportunity to
to he put a ward on him even though he's
not here man and what better way to say
you'll never be forgotten yeah and both
opportunities absolutely
and you know again the people that won
or
they're not they're no slouches it's not
like oh they don't deserve it but
yipes yeah you know the emmys has never
really been a body that that did the
sort of lifetime achievement version of
that where it's like listen we know that
paul newman's best work isn't color of
money i mean it's good but it's not
the dude's been working for 60 years
he's made amazing movies this is a good
enough one to recognize all of that work
you know it's like
i i i i did so what was the denzel movie
that he won for wherever like training
day
training day so he's wonderful in the
movie but you know it's like
that always felt more like sorry we
missed you on that max and everything
else you've ever done
yeah like they they tend to do that like
sort of
it doesn't feel like it it doesn't feel
like you you do that just rewarding like
yeah man you've been like anthony
anderson who was up for blackish he was
nominated eight times i think for the
role but it's like he was a dude who's
been on tv for 40 years
you know and like been pretty good and
then making people laugh and like the
show is it's entering its last season
and like
yeah
you could
wouldn't go wrong
i know were you exaggerating when you're
like he's been on tv for 40 years or has
he been has he been around that long
he's it's not quite 40 years but it's
like 30 years he's been you know in
hollywood working
steadily on tv and movies
um
but yeah it's just the academy tv
academy doesn't roll that way
um
yeah i mean well again
i got no skin in this game i got no
horse in the race and ultimately
you know
awards
they're their own rewards or awards i
don't know i'm trying to be deep here
that's my first draft give me a couple
days i'll come up with something deeper
yeah but
i was thrilled to see ted lasso win
because i [ __ ] love ted last so and
again they should have done all of that
stuff well i was particularly um
thrilled to see uh roy kent win
yeah who i absolutely [ __ ] adore one
of my favorite [ __ ] characters tv
characters ever
um and played masterfully by that guy
who by the way is a podcaster yes
i feel like we need to find a way to get
on his movies podcast
well i was on his podcast when i was in
england and it is a fun podcast it's
like
you
[ __ ] that you take with you to the grave
like is is gallows humor but um and then
when i was watching ted lasso i was like
doc i was on that motherfucker's podcast
very talented uh i love that character i
love
you know what do the kids say ship a
ship [ __ ] keely and roy
um
sidebar
uh where do you stand on the coach beard
episode
um i feel like that is only an episode
you can do in the second season or third
season of the show which is by that
point you're invested to the point where
you're like yeah i will go on a
fellaini-esque romp with this dude and
his like weird-ass bad night
um
like i i dug it but it's very much an
off-speed pitch for that show and i dug
it only because i like that actor and i
like that character
um
you know but but it's
it's a short film it's a tiny little
like
weird la dolce vita kind of you know he
was just this guy here's his emotional
journey here's and the the culmination
of it is he just dances and it's like
this it could have been a silent movie
for all that i needed him to actually
speak
um the only problem i think with it was
that it came just when we were like
all right so what's going to happen with
rebecca and sam
like well hold that thought
we're going to go into the london
underground we're going to play more you
know after hours martin scorsese for an
episode
uh but it seems to have wrangled some
folks some people were like this is
where they jumped the shark and i'm like
i also read that this was
you know they had a 10 episode story
planned out and then apple was like we
want 12. and so they added two extra
episodes one was the christmas episode
which already happened and this was the
other
so they were meant to live outside of
the main storyline
yeah i mean there are some people who
are not in love with this season because
it is about i saw a few articles about
that where i was like come on man what
the [ __ ] this is the bomb that's good
for all the soul man and i saw one piece
with a guy that was tweeting his
his like this is what's wrong with
season two is he was like we hated him
all through season one season one's job
is to make you fall in love with ted
lasso once you fall in love with ted
lasso
that's it that was their point and i was
like well but i
you know i like [ __ ] to keep going like
i like the stories to continue so
i disagreed with that point i've enjoyed
season two i think it's beautiful really
yeah yeah i mean it's it's darker than
season one yeah i mean season one had
these little you know the the the the
clouds had some some darkness on the
edge of them
um but this is clearly about ted and his
the reasons why he has panic attacks the
reasons why he is so sunny the reasons
why he was cleaving so tightly to his
wife who kind of wanted out of the
marriage before he did
you know and and i think i saw in some
like whatever next week on ted lasso
that he's wrestling with the fact that
his father committed suicide
you know and so
yeah like let's get a little deep with
this guy let's let's understand why he
is the way he is
and i think that's a valid question for
any show to ask about their their
protagonist
absolutely brilliant show i'm so happy
um
yeah okay so emmy's happened and that's
that exactly um let's go to talk about
what if indeed
i did not watch what if as they happened
week by week because i was busy with my
head up my own ass making a movie
so i got to watch them all bang bang
bang bang bang
in a row
[ __ ] fantastic
everything that i hope that that series
would be very you know movie-centric
which makes sense because
those are the stories that
largely the audience they're going after
is gonna know it's not like you can't do
like
you know what if [ __ ] bullseye didn't
kill elektra a bunch of the audience
would be like wait who are these people
you know
it makes sense that they're taking the
what if formula
and applying it to the movie stories um
because i think that's the best chance
they got of capturing an audience
helps that they're [ __ ] stunningly
gorgeous pieces of animation
um on top of
what i felt are really strong stories
that doctor strange episode
could have been doctor strange too
you know in a less ambitious world than
[ __ ] where kevin foggy wasn't like nah
we got other plants if you were just
going to do an iron man 2 version of
doctor strange too
that totally would have been a [ __ ]
absolute romp like i wouldn't have
complained if that was the whole [ __ ]
feature
and the most recent episode what if
killmonger [ __ ] saved tony stark
fantastic
a fantastic reinvestigation of a
character and and the fact that they're
getting a lot of these cats
to do their voices
is it just tickles me
it does
like
scream though when
people don't come back you're just like
why
you know like i get robert downey jr
because if you're robert downey jr's
agent you're like if he's ever gonna
utter another word as tony stark
it's gonna be for you know [ __ ]
20 40 million dollars not in a cartoon
but it's crazy the people who did say
yes who are just like yeah i'll do it
yeah i mean it definitely feels a bit
like we were already shooting a marvel
movie with these people yeah and so like
hey man can you be favored just come
into this closet and say these nine
lines and it'll be great um you know
when you get somebody like chadwick to
come back which i i thought that it was
just for the one i thought it was the
what if t'challa was star-lord yeah you
got him for
three of them yeah i think
um
what if t'challa was star-lord
was incredibly charming that was the one
that i was like i don't know if that's
gonna be for me but i loved it i thought
it was so beguiling and it really tells
a story about like how
how a person
affects
other people
it's not like what they did to him it's
like he changed the ravagers you know
and in turn
changed [ __ ] thanos i thought that
was adorable and charming as [ __ ] too
yeah and that is my favorite of of all
of them so far
i don't know i i don't know what's my
favorite well first there's agent carter
which i thought was wonderful but i
wouldn't say that was my favorite
there's only one part of agent carter i
didn't like when she was pushing the
thing back into the dimensional rift and
she's like we have to have a dance and
it's like one thing at a time like
simmer down lady yeah do you deal with
this or deal with the conversation not
both but beautiful be a beautifully
active great piece of animation
what was number two number two is
t'challa star-lord beautiful
number three was who's killing the
avengers which seems to be the one that
everybody was [ __ ] on but i i dug it
i thought it was [ __ ] dope man a
murder mystery like with spoilers wait
for it
[ __ ] hank pym in it i thought it was
dope yeah i i i liked it
a friend of mine you know she's her big
issue
about the middle section of these is i
don't necessarily want to keep watching
my heroes die and so i would like for
them to stop killing everybody because i
don't enjoy this um
but the thing that the thing that i
didn't quite dig about that one was
it it pivots on the idea that hank pym
is going to kill all the avengers
because his daughter
was sent off to some mission by nick
fury and died in in the field and so as
for revenge he's killing the people who
mean things to nick fury but the
avengers don't mean anything to them yet
because they're not the avengers yet
they're literally lists names on a list
so he's i'm going to kill
[ __ ] this professor who you haven't
met yet and i'm going to go kill that
says guardian who you haven't talked to
yet and i'm going to kill that like it's
it's a little out of whack like i dug it
but it was like oh murder ministry neat
this is the murder mystery and this is
why huh okay
[Music]
uh the fourth one was doctor strange
you're muted
doctor strange could totally be a movie
as previously said um what was uh oh the
marvel zombies
i thought was totally fun
um
you know
like and and kind of a no-brainer to do
literally
yeah
um yeah i've there for my money there's
not been a weak one yet the weakest one
the one that everybody was like uh why
do they keep killing the avengers i you
know and i'm with you in terms of like
you know could have been could have used
a better
impetus but at the same time you know
bad guys are crazy and
bad guys be bad guys and and sometimes
like when a good guy flips like
you know at least they gave it an
emotional core i i i yeah i went for
that episode so far so good man like i i
think it's blissful and the opening
credits feel very 70s to me the whole
thing has a real like [ __ ] in search
of vibe to it
uh my friend walter flanagan said that
um he said he just wishes that
owatu would introduce all the episodes
like
rod sterling you know because they have
him talk but you don't like necessarily
see him he's in the clouds and stuff
they're like why don't they just have
him come out and talk and i was like
yeah
yeah my biggest gripe especially for
them the two most recent
is the endings is that it they're
starting to feel a little bit like
like an snl sketch that just doesn't
know how to end itself so it just stops
it's like all right cool killmonger
saves tony stark and then he's going to
kill tony and he's going to do this and
awesome and he's going back to wakanda
he's gonna [ __ ] take over and that's
badass and then and then
and then it just kind of stops
it's like all right so i guess i guess
shuri and pepper are gonna team up to do
something but i don't know what that is
um are we ever gonna get a follow-up to
the story i don't know i don't know what
seasons two or three of what if are
supposed to be i don't know but
you know marvel zombies like all right
we're gonna go back to wakanda what kind
of has been invaded and
we stopped the episode before we get to
wakanda it's like oh okay
sure
i i guess
that's how you could end it
um i don't know what that means i don't
know how that resides just kind of
stops are they meant to
sequalize are they meant to like go back
to the stories are they meant to like
cross over at a certain point we don't
know you know like they they have not
come out and said at some point these
things will tie together um it doesn't
feel as if the we killed all the
avengers can then lead into you know
[ __ ]
i guess it could lead into marvel
zombies because they're all avengers are
dead um but like how t'challa star-lord
figures into
you know killmonger v black panther like
it feels like they're standalone
anthologies but yeah that that is my one
issue is the
how are these supposed to end
um
in chat mark just a few
lou noel says keep your head still damn
it that one's obviously a gift
um but there was one here uh russell
cook said what if
disney paid scarlett right the first
time
damn i know shall we talk about that
since somebody else brought it up
um i mean i don't know where the current
lawsuit is at this point i guess it was
a thing we missed while you were gone
but the idea that because disney put
black widow
on disney plus disney premier
premier access
that it violates scarlet's contract
which had very robust box office
performance
incentives
and even though it was also in theaters
but it was also on disney plus and did
that water down what could potentially
have been a more
uh lucrative payday
um
it seems as if this past year and a half
has been one in which hollywood has had
to grapple with what it means for these
theatrical windows to close you know
what it means to premiere you know 200
million dollar movies on a streaming
service and it's not as simple as well
we have the movie let's just put it out
it's no no there's a bunch of people who
you know are contractually owed things
that you are now in a position to not
give them um
you know warner brothers had to make
lots of rapid deals when they decided to
put their entire 20 21 slate on hbo max
simultaneously
um
some people were pleased some people
were fundamentally not pleased one dude
refused to ever work with the studio
again
um
and so it's it's it is still playing out
i think the the skull at which of it all
that one guy who was like i don't want
to ever work with these cats again
literally went across the street maybe
i'll be able to make a movie with uh
universal yeah i will bring you my adam
bob movie
okay
um there are so many uh people in chat
telling us a bunch of things uh
that we should be talking about mad
salty skills is kevin high
i'm 51 i don't get high i get centered
um that being said
no
uh shall we dive into the news because i
imagine a lot of the things i'm going to
pull as stuff that you're from the chat
here this stuff that you're already
ready to talk about um i feel like
there's two quick things we can talk
about have you seen any of why the last
minute yet not yet how is it have you
watched it i watched the first two
episodes i think there are four
currently up now um it's really well
done
like it's it's it feels the way the
comic kind of felt
updated in ways that were inevitable
um namely
there are lots of people who have y
chromosomes who are who are not men
and there are people who present as men
who do not have y chromosomes um so so
they're they're
steering right into the issue of trans
um identity and gender politics and all
that stuff which did they address in the
book no almost not at all
um and they're it's it's front and
center in the show this is is this brian
k vaughn is he the crank avon and
piaguera are both creators and executive
producers of the show they work on the
actual show yeah i mean i i i and it's
it's unclear how much more they had to
do with this show than than brian had to
do with say runaways which he was a
creative consultant on um which is sure
i really enjoyed i really enjoyed it um
you know so it's like the casting is
great it feels big it feels apocalyptic
whatever your particular desire and or
temperature is for looking at a pandemic
end of the world scenario
um your mileage may vary you know if you
are exhausted at the idea of you know
cities under siege and
chaos and what's killing all of the men
like all of that stuff is is for all the
reasons why it feels very
um relevant today it could also feel a
bit like don't want this in my life
right now
um the one thing that i will say is two
episodes in and they've done a very good
job of balancing the story
but it still feels odd
to do a story about
um how women have to rebuild the world
but the story is kind of following the
one guy that's left
right you know like it's it's inherent
in the idea it's it's part of the
premise but it's like is this really the
dude who's the most interesting part of
the story
um
and so they they do
bounce the story around a lot to the
various women that that are that are
dealing with the end of the world but
every time you come back to yorick
you're like
i mean yeah sure i guess but
he's the least interesting person here
so far
who's uh who's in the cast and people
any famous faces um the biggest famous
face is diane lane who's playing the
president
um yeah yorick york and hiro's mom
um
but everybody else feels like
fantastic canadian character actors
how is that where they shop i think so
yeah
um all right
and then very quickly hawkeye trailer
did you watch
yes
beguiling yes
so [ __ ] charming charm city
um has a real die hard vibe to it maybe
just all the christmas stuff but uh
i i was i honestly when they announced
that show i was like i can give a [ __ ]
about hawkeye and after i saw that
trailer i'm like i am so [ __ ] in it
looks like
the matt fraction miniseries very much
so
uh and that's smart like you know keep
[ __ ] stealing from the best you know
and i'm not stealing when i guess you
own all the comics but
it belongs to us what a great [ __ ]
choice i mean like there's some [ __ ]
that's like flipped like you know
there's a scene at the end of the
trailer where she's
using the arrow and [ __ ] you know
blowing up the [ __ ] uh
the uh the [ __ ] tracksuit mafia truck
or whatever [ __ ] but um in the comic
it's reverse she's at the wheel and he's
firing [ __ ] arrows and stuff so it's
yeah just beautiful who knew man [ __ ]
like these [ __ ] can't
lose you know like [ __ ] even hawkeye
which i was like yeah well that was the
same way about loki i was like i'll
watch it but i don't really give a [ __ ]
and then i wound up liking it more than
i imagined i would and this seems the
exact same way like it really feels it
feels like uh
feels like a fun ride one that i want to
go on feels warm feels wonderful do you
think his wife will be back in it i see
him talking to her at one point but yeah
i mean it seems a little odd that that
you see him with his kids but not with
his wife maybe his ex-wife you know it's
entirely possible that a wife would
might be done
with being attached to the superhero
life to leave this leave this guy sort
of alone so he can live his best
rockford files life um training the next
hawkeye but yeah i'm [ __ ] here for it
banana stand in chat says loki wasn't
very good um it wasn't very bad either
like uh
and had really wonderful magical moments
and stuff i i i think marvel's tv record
their disney plus record is pretty
strong so far did you see they announced
disney plus day
yeah they're going to put i think it's
november 12th or something they're
putting
uh shang chi on on their on disney plus
plus a number of
new things that they're mocking on that
day disney plus day they've already got
their own holiday mark they do like
prime day but for disney
um and then the last bit was the matrix
resurrection trailer
i you know when they announced they were
making this movie i was like i'll go
back [ __ ] you know
particularly if it's even one of the
wachowskis and and it is correct like
not both wishowski's just one director
correct yeah i think lily is the one who
came back but alana was like
i don't want to do so at least there's
you know a tie to the brilliance of the
original um
so you know when i heard they're doing
it again i'm like right i'm like what am
i not going to [ __ ] watch a matrix
but it was not like you know oh where
show me the trailer like i was like i'll
see it when i see it i enjoyed the [ __ ]
out of that trailer man that looks like
it's gonna be a good [ __ ] time yeah
no i'm i'm i'm excited for it despite
the fact that yeah the last two were uh
were not good
um so much times gone by all is forgiven
i'm hoping yes fingers crossed um all
right should we get to the news
yeah we can uh we could definitely get
to the news because the [ __ ] chat is
telling us what's well here uh atac
graffiti superhero is yelling in all
caps spider-man trailer we didn't even
talk about we didn't get to talk about
that we did not get to talk about that
um fantastic my uh i spectacular we
should say um
i'm i'm kind of hoping
that we get six trailers or teasers
and
they build the sinister six like this
was the doc ock one
maybe next we get you know and it all
builds up to norman osborne as the last
one maybe that's just me reading into it
but
it felt very
like okay here's your doc ock and then
if if i was marketing it
i would be like let's do six teaser
trailers that
introduced the sinister six and then
the main the final trailer before
release
puts them all in whatever the [ __ ] i
mean look nobody wants [ __ ] marketing
notes for me i made yogozers i
understand
that being said
i you know we all it smells like they're
doing the sinister six so i wouldn't be
surprised if we saw
six different trailers or very very true
i hope so but i loved it i i you know
that is they got my number man and
[ __ ] i i the one thing i i will say
that i was surprised is that at least as
portrayed in the trailer and that's not
to be
trusted you know marketing cuts things
up and arrange things in ways that
perhaps they won't be when you see the
feature
but i thought the
entry into the multiverse based on the
trailer this is not a criticism
but was a little like
you know far out space nuts
like you know lunch launch i said launch
you know
very much like you know peter stop
[ __ ] with the spell you [ __ ] with
the spell
i'll take any way how we get into the
multiverse i just
for some reason i thought it would be
like you know
multiversal war or some dimensional
breach by the bad guys but
it's very on brand to have young peter
be
the cause of his own problems so i guess
it totally tracks i didn't i didn't bump
into it but i was like oh that's how
they're going to get into the multiverse
by accident yeah
and it's also like
and it is the the fact that doctor
strange is so willing to engage with
what is clearly a uh a a a transgression
in the rules of time and space
has led people to be like is that really
doctor strange maybe that's not doctor
strange maybe it's
mafisto
i saw a few of those there's everyone
like they always want to throw mephisto
into the mix
in every [ __ ] show man they're like
it's got to be mephisto it could just be
the dark doctor strange from what if
you know where he [ __ ]
you know there's another they showed us
another doctor strange who sounded like
the guy but it was more driven and [ __ ]
so i you know there's one line in the
trailer which everyone was like that's
franco but i thought it sounded like
benedict cumberbatch sounded like doctor
strange but just being
like a little more sinister so maybe
there's a few doctor strangers it's a
multiversal movie so chances are
we will see more than one doctor strange
could be
very well
um all right before we get to the news
proper um we should do our second ad of
the night
for keeps yeah for keeps uh for you
literally for creeps we're doing an ad
for keeps right now kids and you know
what keeps does
they allow you to hold on to your hair
something i wish had been invented back
when i made
mall rats in 1995. i'm sure i've told
this story before mark but my mom
her first note when she saw mall rats uh
after the movie was done she said well
i'm just so glad that you and jason got
to run around you could use the exercise
tiger then the next thing she said mark
was
you know when you put your head through
the wall and your hat fell off i noticed
you had a bald spot in the back and i
was like ma
i wish keeps had existed back then mark
because i would have been like
immediately
getting in touch with the good folks at
keeps
going to that
that address keeps.com
fat man
and ordering up a ton of keeps so i
could keep the hair that i had that that
hair is long gone
mark
i remember she said she's like you've
got a ball spot the size of a quarter
now it's the size of texas mr president
like
[Laughter]
billy bob thornton from armageddon yeah
i'm going old school tonight i'm making
references to armageddon i'm making
references to far out space nuts where
else are you going to find that on the
internet tonight kids where's kevin
jersey no 1973 yeah you've been watching
a lot of bob denver [ __ ] that's not
gilligan
eeps
keeps uh offers a simple stress-free way
to keep your hair kids and this goes for
men and women this ain't just a boy
thing this is also a girl thing
convenient virtual doctor consultations
and medications delivered straight to
your door every three months man so you
don't even have to leave your home which
we've all become very accustomed to
cost treatments start at just 10 bucks a
month and keeps offers generic versions
as well very discreet packaging and
proven results keeps has more five-star
reviews than any of its competitors
prevention is key kids treatments can
take four to six months to see results
so act fast the idea is you get to keep
your hair man
like it's they're like
that's their mission
they're not saying like we're gonna grow
new hair for you they're like no we're
gonna we're gonna have you keeping the
hair that you got
and trust me in the race
that's that's that's what you're looking
for slow and steady wins the race we all
know that [ __ ] story indeed
um so if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to keeps.com keps
dot com slash fat man to receive your
first month of treatment for free that's
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash fat man to get
your first month three
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash fat man
i also slight disclaimer do not think
this is appropriate for women to use is
that right i believe so
let's see
is that
let me see
kept on
scrolling offers two out of three men
will experience some form of hair loss
by the time they're 35.
more than 50 million men
in the u.s suffer from male
pattern baldness i think you're on to
something here mark
so yeah go to keeps.com slash fat man 20
off your first order sorry first month
treatment for free
uh do not give it to your wife and her
girlfriend or sister yeah apparently
it's a boy thing it's just for dudes
just for dudes
uh we thank the good folks at keeps
whose product i haven't understood until
tonight apparently
i did not know it was gender specific
but i guess that makes sense on some
chemicals
you're right you're right uh we thank
the good folks at keeps.com for
believing in us
still
uh even though
even though i'm i was
confused on the central thesis of the
entire thing apparently until mark
made it clear that
i misread
our copy
only for safety reasons
kids don't listen to a strange old man
on the internet when he tells you to
give your mother
something
just
you know always find a friend like mark
who can be a sounding boy
are you sure
um all right i know we uh mark's got
some [ __ ] to do as does jc so we gotta
keep this [ __ ] track movie what do
you guys got to blow it like uh 745 or
some so [ __ ] yeah about that um
so yes
uh the news we got three news stories
tonight um
the first of which
i found very interesting which is
marshall hold on this just in from peace
mullins in chat
trans man here and i've heard a lot of
other trans men have found success
in growing facial hair with keeps and
similar products there you go all right
look at that so
excellent consultation man
telling you chad is a
is amazing yes sometimes it's filled
with people calling me a cuck or
whatever the [ __ ] but like generally
speaking there's a lot of useful
information that comes from chat yeah in
fact they're telling us what they want
to [ __ ]
what they want us to talk about
apparently there's a ghostbusters
afterlife trailer that just happened or
are they talking about the old one
um i think they might be talking about
an old one i liked it
pretty good yeah i'm ready i ain't
against this i'm for it kids i thought
maybe there was a new one that just
happened yeah not that i saw today but
we we've been busy for the last two
hours uh let me ask you this as we head
into the news um is
marcia lucas a part of the news
top story let's let's begin there man
because
i found this incredibly charming like
it's just one of those stories about
like an older person who's like
i'm gonna say whatever the [ __ ] i want
come on get this oscar that i have
for editing star wars got the bona fides
to back it up and they're done doing
what they were doing so she waited
respectfully she didn't
you know go [ __ ] in the [ __ ] punch
bowl while the movies were going on she
waited until we they were in the rear
view
but
man oh man
yes
reminds me of my sassy grandmother just
indeed so let me read apparently marcia
lucas yes read the quote
marcia lucas was interviewed for uh jw
the late j.w renzler's book howard
kazanjian
a producer's life who produced very many
of george's movies
i like kathleen kennedy i always liked
her she was full of beans she was really
smart and really bright really wonderful
woman and i liked her husband frank i
liked him a lot now that she's running
lucasfilm and making movies it seems to
me that kathy kennedy and jj abrams
don't have a clue about star wars
they don't get it and j.j abrams is
writing these stories when i saw that
movie where they kill han solo i was
furious i was furious when they killed
han solo
absolutely positively there was no rhyme
or reason to it
i thought you don't get the jedi story
you don't get the magic of star wars
you're getting rid of han solo
that was her first quote
i mean she wasn't done no no no she also
uh she also railed against
the decision to kill luke skywalker in
the last jedi
they have luke disintegrate marcia lucas
says they killed han solo they killed
luke skywalker and they don't have
princess delay anymore and they're
spitting out movies every year
and they think it's important to appeal
to a woman's audience and now their main
character is this female who's supposed
to have jedi powers but we don't know
how she got jedi powers or who she is
it sucks
the story lines are terrible just
terrible awful you can quote me jj
abrams kathy kennedy
talk to me
oh
this is about star wars
because those i i thought somebody was
coming after me about masters of the
universe i it
sounded very similar
mark i'm in no position to comment on a
franchise that
uh you know plays games with their main
characters uh as we all well know at
this point uh i'm just
shocked
that
that you know
it came out ever like
that
you know
i find it i
you know i i can disagree or whatever
the [ __ ] but i i find it incredibly
charming
she was like uh are we clear all right
here we go here's what i really thought
and
say what you will but this is the woman
that cut american graffiti for heaven's
sakes
yeah i mean she's the woman who you know
killed obi-wan kenobi she's got an oscar
for it yeah and you know
inarguably
i would say you know as she was there
with george while he was building the
[ __ ] franchise
she does know a lot about these
characters and she does you know
probably have something emotionally
invested in these characters and like
you know i
i've respected the direction they went
with the story and whatnot better than
anything i could have done but like yeah
i didn't want to see [ __ ] han and
luke go
um so i can't imagine
how
somebody who was there for [ __ ] the
building of this [ __ ] like
felt seeing them go let alone
the way they went but um wow you know
yeah
you know and also this was apparently
the interview was conducted between
the last jedi and rise of skywalker so
it is not commenting on the
culmination of the skywalker saga
um she said this before
yeah even though the book was just
published that's when the interview was
conducted before rise of skywalker
correct
i'm going to go out on limb here mark
not necessarily a hot take and say if
she didn't like force awakens
i can't imagine
she improved her opinion
with rise of skywalker right although it
would have answered her question
we don't know who this woman is or how
she got her powers
if the answer is though she's
palpatine's great granddaughter or
whatever the [ __ ]
it would have uh yeah it would have
answered a question i don't based on her
comments
i don't mean
satisfied
martial lucas
yeah
at all it is it is to your point there
is always something wonderful about
someone who has nothing left to lose um
he was like
come for me what are you going to do
like my feelings honestly like i'm 51 it
just gives me heart to know to know that
one day
you know when i'm in my 60s or 70s like
i'm not gonna give a [ __ ] anymore i'm
just gonna be like let me tell you some
things
[Laughter]
yeah when uh
when uh when jordan peels kid decides he
wants to make clerks four
and you're like let me tell you
right
you think i would [ __ ] be against
that i'd be like oh my god he's relevant
yes make the [ __ ] out of clerks for you
want me in it you want me not in it i'll
do anything
it opens with silent bob's funeral
[ __ ] you oh my god i'll carry that
character for you son of jordan
um but yeah and to your point also just
for out of curiosity why is that to be
the son of jordan beale not jordan beale
himself
because i feel like we weren't some
generational distance i feel like we
want something like
jj was not a contemporary of yours or of
george's oh i see what you're doing
there i see what you're doing you know
it's like this young kid who grew up
loving my ex-husband's movies has now
decided he wants to make his version of
it and he doesn't know what star wars is
look i don't know jordan peels them adam
but i can't imagine he encourages his
son to make remakes particularly a
[ __ ] like clerks
not a remake he was actually making it
number four
that so he's taking over for me it's not
even like they're remaking my [ __ ] yeah
it's just like i'm gonna continue the
story just picking it up where it left
off
30 years later
no i still go with it i'm like we'll
probably get an easier time getting
people in the audience than i will
put asses in seats
yeah jordan's appeals kids
that's all i'm hearing in this story i'm
like why would he want to do clerks for
uh batman
yeah i wanted to point out ace moonshot
and chad said marcia lucas was always
the heart of star wars
and another quote that she had in that
book was talking about how people always
credit her with being the heart of star
wars and that it's completely untrue
that it's all george
um and then she also goes on to [ __ ] on
the prequels quite a bit as well said
she walked out of episode one crying
um
she hates everybody who made star wars
after she did not just jj
fair enough what about empire no she
worked on empire a little bit she didn't
get credited but she did edit she said
yeah i think she and george split
right around return of the jedi which is
why you got uh indiana jones in the
temple of doom where do you sit with all
this
uh banff man as a huge star wars fan
uh more so than even myself you can
quote chapter and verse of
extended universe things uh how did
those comments sit with you and did they
dissuade you or change your opinion in
any way shape or form um i think it's
interesting that she was quiet until a
few years ago and then she did a
screening where they talked to like her
and john dykstra and all the people who
are kind of not with lucasfilm anymore
um at the academy and i think that kind
of like
warmed her up to go out there and start
speaking her mind um
i thought her comments on i i liked how
uh
because it's something that i hear all
the time from people my age and older
that
well marsha saved star wars george is an
idiot um so i'm glad that she came out
and talked on that that made me happy
um i
am a big star wars prequels fan but i
thought her criticism of the prequels
wasn't
too far off
um
and i guess i have to be very careful
about what i how i say this
uh
i think if you're going to
to
um
i think if you're gonna
[ __ ] on kathleen kennedy about the
sequel trilogy you have to equally prop
her up for
mandalorian and bad batch and all the
stuff that we love
because
she wasn't the one behind
the
writing of those movies or the directing
of those movies she's the one giving the
thumbs up or the thumbs down and she did
give thumbs up on mandalorian and book
of boba fett and all the stuff we're
very excited about so i think if you're
gonna tear her down for the stuff you
don't like you still have to give her
props and not be like well that's john
favreau yeah but
she's the one who's giving john writing
john favreau's checks you know
look at this guy that's very diplomatic
of you well done jc it's so easy to
[ __ ] roast the flesh and stuff and
you give it's a different perspective
well done but but i also don't disagree
with what marcia lucas said about the
sequels so
um i mean
i i can't agree or disagree it's
somebody's opinion right but like i do
lend her opinion
more credibility based on the fact that
she was like you know
i laid the track upon which every
[ __ ] train that says star wars rolls
so
i get to say [ __ ] like you know i'm like
lily you were there you were there for
the keystone she was there when they
laid the [ __ ] keystone
she's got this hardware to prove it
you can watch a video on youtube where
she talks about
the edits what she did what she brought
to it
i also believe that like i don't know if
this is fact but i think it's probably
true in one form or another
that
harrison ford made it a condition of
returning that you killed han solo
i i had
thought that i heard that as as well
which i'm sure marcia lucas
i'm not sure but i imagine she might
argue then don't
include han solo right
um but i i remember that too when she
said you kill han solo i was like well i
thought he only said he would do it only
if they killed han solo i don't for some
reason i thought i read that yeah me too
and then also that he had wanted han to
die and return the jedi
but sort of backed off of that stance
and to to get your happy yummy up ending
um
in chat
uh kevin foster says did they talk about
candyman not yet we will yeah i haven't
seen him yet lou no i saw it talking
about lou nahwell says a clerk's reboot
fully
people of color casted and written would
be great
lou i point you to a wonderful feature
called friday
which
ice cube himself has said like oh i was
i was just doing clerks so if you were
ever curious what
that version of clerks would look like
you could see it you can see a bunch of
them i believe he's made quite a few
yeah damn
they're all better than clerks i assure
you
though but check that out don't don't
sleep on these friday pictures i don't
know if you've heard of them this chris
tucker he's got a future yeah friday
next friday friday after next
all the fridays and every fridays and
then saturday candy man i enjoyed um it
ties in to the other one it doesn't like
you know go like everything you [ __ ]
saw in the last movie was wrong
um
i enjoyed it i thought it was well made
it was creepy definitely unsettled me
and stuff what is that director
directing in marvel world she's doing
the marvels
[Music]
captain marvel too [ __ ] gorgeous
beautifully shot is something i never
noticed but opening credit sequences
looked like she just shot like the idea
was they just shot up at the buildings
in chicago
on a you know a [ __ ] cloudy day and
it is creepy
because you're looking at the sky but
the sky is broken up by a layer of
clouds so it looks like these buildings
are like half built hanging upside down
in the sky very unsettling way to open
the moon right then and there i was like
oh [ __ ] hire her for to make a marvel
movie there's somebody with vision and
stuff so i thought it was a good-looking
movie
um and what's his name yayaz just
continues to [ __ ] destroy what a
wonderful actor
can't wait to see him as baby morpheus
is that for sure who he's playing i
think so yeah
so does that mean that we won't see
older morpheus there's no lawrence
fishburne in this movie
according to lawrence fishman
yeah i know he said that but we live in
that world where
people say things
aren't true
it could be misleading could be taken in
any number of ways
it doesn't necessarily have to be a lie
it just could be
perspective but um yeah he was he seemed
very declarative
when he was like they haven't called me
i hope he's kidding i hope he did a
secret bit yeah
not too late
it's not too late when does that come
out
uh december
oh is that right yeah and that's another
hbo max debut too right yep that feels
weird man
didn't it
yeah i mean look i'm all for it i'm
fighting it because i got hbo max i got
a big ass tv so i'm just as happy to sit
home and watch it but
if i if i was them i'd be like nah this
one we're gonna [ __ ] theater at first
and
but what do i know what do we know
all right second news item there is a
penguin prequel series coming to hbo max
um
yeah they are spinning off from an hbo
max a penguin prequel tv series spinning
out of the batman movie um
who's isn't he being played by uh colin
farrell
and he's gonna do a tv show
you know it's unclear how much of a
prequel it is if it's young penguin if
it's just like a week before the movie
or years before the movie
[ __ ] boy i wish we knew what that
looked like if only some tv show had
charted the growth of
the penguin
over the course of many seasons indeed
fancy that
um but according to deadline it will be
a scarface-like origin story that traces
the rise of oswald copperpot's criminal
empire
um no actors are confirmed to star on
the project but farrell apparently has
been approached to reprise his role
[Music]
i'm in i'll watch as many batman tv
shows as they want to give us
yeah and it's coming like matt reeves is
going to executive produce it
um so at the very least i trust matt
reeves and it will feel like the movie
in tone if not in budget but here wayne
doran's in chat says older morpheus
died in the video game and they are
continuing after the video game so it's
not just the movies they're doing the
the video game the online game is all
part of the story so apparently morpheus
died in the game how weird to be yes i
mean i know they weren't expecting to
make more movies but it's like
and also like
continuity is only your friend if you
want it to be and like
if they if they decided to ignore it
nobody would care i'll never forget like
i think it was on last jedi you and i
were talking and um
you know you were like he should have
just gone to the planet and i was like
mark he can't because the ship was in
the water and he had an earthquake and
he was like
well you know that's only because ryan
johnson just didn't give him those
things right you mean if you give him
those things he could go and i was like
oh my god you're right like i went for
the logic 100 and [ __ ] and i'm like yeah
i guess he could have changed it
um
our last news story um for this
abbreviated episode is
i believe this is one of your favorite
comic books matt wagner's grendel
yes is coming to netflix as a
live-action tv show [ __ ] a it's about
time oh my god they could do so many
stories are they doing
which one grendel prime hunter rose are
they doing christine sparr they're doing
hunter rose
um
yeah
finally that means mage won't be far
behind [ __ ]
grendel is a wicked [ __ ] story you
want to talk about anti-hero jesus
oh you think they're doing argent as a
wolf i bet you they do now oh my god
they totally will i remember like years
ago when they were trying to make
grendel and [ __ ] in the [ __ ] 90s the
early aughts they were like well
argent's not going to be a wolf like
he's going to be wolf you know like
he'll have like bushy eyebrows or some
[ __ ] but in the age of netflix argent
will be a flat out [ __ ] wolf man
there's no way they don't do it we they
make [ __ ] sweet tooth for christ's
sakes there's a deer boy so there's no
way that they don't do [ __ ] hunter
rose's main arch nemesis as
argent the wolf that's so [ __ ] up my
god i'm going to see everything become a
movie in the tv show that i ever loved
before i die isn't that right
it's all for you damien it's all it
really is my god
it's my simulation isn't it
so weird that in my simulation i'm not
more successful but like maybe i'm just
that humble guy where i'm like yeah it's
my simulation but i don't have to be the
best
that can be no way and also what more do
i need than i already have
the way i feel every day i'm the day of
my life
um supernatural uh alum andrew dab is
gonna be the writer and showrunner a
fellow named abu
abubakar ali is said to play hunter rose
um jamie ray newman as jocasta rose
julian black antelope as argent
um madeleine ziemann as liz sparks kevin
corrigan as barry palumbo emma hoe as
stacy palumbo eric palladino as teddy
chicony
um brittany allen as annabelle wright
and andy menchus as larry stoller who's
doing the show
on netflix but did they say who's like
the creator of the show or a fellow
named andrew dabb
who is on supernatural for some of their
900 episodes good for him i [ __ ]
support this 100 i'll totally watch
[ __ ] grendel man like what a cool
mask what a cool idea
everything about he's a [ __ ] assassin
it's a two-prong [ __ ] knife oh i mean
this you know the spirit this
[ __ ] lends itself to a netflix show
this
i i support this what a good idea what
excellent great world we live in where
they're gonna do this [ __ ]
yeah there's a quote from matt wagner
season two they probably i mean they
could do hunter rose season one they can
keep hunter rose going for seasons but
they he then he did the female grendel
which i actually liked a little bit more
this is the panzer brother art if i
remember craig maybe i'm wrong but um my
god that was a great character
and a great look the grendel mask is
very cool chasing amy they're grendel
prince all over
banky and holden's apartment because
those were my [ __ ] grendel fence i'm
a huge matt wagner fan so if we get this
that means we're getting closer to mage
and mage lends itself to the era of
netflix i hope this just gives way to
that mage is so [ __ ] pun intended
magical so great if you've never read
matt wagner's uh
uh grendel you know now's the time to
start but even better than grendel is
his his book mage the first one
particularly the hero discovered
it's our update on the arthurian legend
so [ __ ] charming so wonderful so
emotional the umbra sprite like oh god
just
simple clear lines of good and evil like
such a mythical story and
a book that like was just far ahead of
its time like nowadays like you know why
the last man fables [ __ ] like that
they they're they're on the track that
matt wagner laid for sure i'm happy to
hear that grendel's getting a show man
that's [ __ ] dope it's gonna work
yeah no release date yet um and it's not
in production yet but uh but it's coming
it's coming
i um
i'm uh dragon honored 99 and chad is
going isn't bone coming soon too yes
so is usagi yujimbo i know [ __ ] by
by taika watiti of all people
like
think about that like think about it
whenever you know you hear people be
like this is the worst [ __ ]
simulation it's like yeah but at least
the shows are good
you know we can be in one of those
simulations where everything sucks and
the shows are bad too
[Laughter]
so at least it gives us something you
know i guess we do live in the matrix
because it's just like
i'm like you can oh you can [ __ ]
red pill me all day long as long as you
[ __ ] give me them good good shows man
yeah i will sit in the bathtub with a
rubber ducky on my head as long as
there's a really good show on the screen
in front of me is it blue pill or red
pill which is which is the one where you
remain in [ __ ] ignorance i think it's
the blue pill you stay you stay under
and the red pill is
see how see how deep the rabbit hole
goes kids i've seen i saw i saw a rabbit
hole once
i took a fistful of blue pills
i don't want to know what's down that
[ __ ] rabbit hole
that's for better smarter people we want
to get out of this life in one piece
blissfully ignorant
happy in my own little bubble making
dopey kevin smith [ __ ] until i [ __ ]
go toes out i don't need to go down to
[ __ ] i like that the matrix tells me
exactly what the steak tastes like
[Laughter]
you can just call me kevin pants
nice
um all right before we go kids uh
because there's some [ __ ] to do let's
see did we miss any holy [ __ ]
sometimes you just pop in the chat and
look at a [ __ ] comment and go yes
braden goss
if if you think of nothing else think of
this he says
roy kent
brett goldstein
for wolverine
um
yeah because he would call scott summers
a a wanker in the perfect [ __ ] way
wanaka you're a wanker mate um okay
[ __ ] god squad we talked did we not talk
about this no i guess not while we were
[ __ ] making clerks yeah
loved it
liked it
exactly that we were yeah you know
the moment i heard from dave despalchen
years ago that starro was the villain i
was like there's no way this movie
doesn't [ __ ] rule and
it ruled it was wonderful i i was happy
to see starro bust out and [ __ ]
i thought taika waititi was the voice of
was going to be the voice of star i
didn't know he's just playing rat
catcher's dad
i would if it were me i would have made
him [ __ ] starro like
hey guys
yeah hello
hello i'm i can't do the accent i'm not
trying to do the voice but
but yeah i enjoyed the [ __ ] out he's so
gifted james gunn i'll watch him do a
marvel do a dc
i might watch him do my wife if she was
into it if she was just like look i want
him to rock my world like starro
from the beautiful balls of james gunn
um he's so [ __ ] talented
good for him um but yes i enjoyed that
um rest in peace george carlin
yeah
i mean you're a little late rest in
peace norm mcdonald though we should
definitely
uh point out that we lost norm mcdonald
this week a very very funny uh man
which i just i totally forgot until
you know a bunch of the articles that
have run this week canadian
really
that's what they said i was like oh
um yes a huge loss uh cancer i believe
never met him but i always thought he
was really [ __ ] funny yeah he
apparently kept it very private
yeah i i don't understand those people i
mean i know bill maher was on tv this
weekend going like that's the way it
should be comics shouldn't tell you
their problems but
oh my god i [ __ ]
i don't know if you heard this mark but
i had a heart attack when
yeah
you know i i i like i'll tell you
everything i don't know these people
that suffer in silence like they have
all my respect i gotta spread my
suffering around and [ __ ] so i let
everybody know what's going on
uh but he'll be missed uh big bucket of
wind as we say on hollywood babylon
um
michael k williams
another [ __ ] huge loss we mentioned
him earlier in the evening when we were
talking about the emmys but
omar little yeah
and chalky white and
white montrose
i never saw the night of but apparently
he's amazing in the night of is that
right yeah
yeah um there's a there's a fan if
you're interested and haven't already
there's a fantastic marc maron episode
with michael k williams um
that's about a year old maybe maybe it's
even february of this year um just
talking about his life and his
perspectives on things and his struggles
with sobriety and you know what what
pulls him into addiction and how he sort
of lives his life day by day is like
today i'm good you know and today is a
gift and that's that's why they call it
the present um
but but yeah it's it is both wonderful
to hear the amount of joy that he has
for his work and for his craft and for
life
and it's tragic to listen to
um
given his his very recent departure
he came to my house
years ago we were doing this morning
show me and jen used to host like a
morning podcast and um
we were massive fans of the wire and he
was in town he came over and what a
lovely guy he was been really committed
to the craft true like actor deep in his
blood such a nice guy i tried to put him
in
something twice
uh both times he was like i would love
to but he was working on a thing he was
constantly booked as you would imagine
yeah um yeah huge huge huge loss um
rosario dawson showing up on aew last
week
huge
[ __ ] huge jumping over to [ __ ]
barrier and getting into the match
uh wonderful she is fantastic in clerks
three absolutely [ __ ] magical
um thank god we were able to
get her before she
heads off into
outer space and one yes or nine other
different ip based lands i mean like
my god she constantly works she's so
wonderful i i mean
granted like i'm biased but like i was
thinking about it particularly after
this time around in clerks 3.
she has to be my favorite actress and
not just because like i've worked with
her like
she's always doing interesting [ __ ]
she's worked with like every [ __ ]
director there is
i this time around when we were sitting
around on clerk's three at one point i
was like
so we were talking about you know
malcolm made a documentary about me
i was like you need to [ __ ] let
somebody make a documentary about you
because she's got like an amazing life
story
and
it's not done like her [ __ ] journey
gets more and more interesting so yeah
we got lucky
to find a window where we were able to
get her into the flick and whatnot
outstanding
uh let's see
um
malignant you watch that
no because i'm a big ass [ __ ] um
but a friend of mine wrote it my friend
kayla akayla cooper who's been on the
podcast actually she was on an episode
of black man beyond is that right i'm
talking about horror because that's her
jam she's she's a black lady who loves
horror movies and writes horror movies
um apparently it's amazing and bonkers
and crazy and ridiculous in all the
great ways and i told her at some point
i will watch it on my phone in the
middle of a park in broad daylight um
because i'm that kind of um wuss when it
comes to horror
did you see the peacemaker teaser
trailer somebody's asking i did not is
there was there's an hbo max like [ __ ]
that's upcoming
and i think it had a couple of
seconds of peacemaker um i don't think
there's been anything more than that but
i could be wrong
um and and of course
lots of
um shang qi
yes which i liked quite a bit
when did you see it i saw it opening
weekend
um i went out to the uh to the theater
um and like listen i love it that it's a
legit martial arts movie and it does not
[ __ ] around with that like
they they got choreographers who know
their business they got a lead actor who
can do the the work they gotta it's
surrounded by cast who's phenomenal tony
lion is great as the bad guy like you
think he's he's doing some really
interesting stuff
um
but for me it fell a bit into the marvel
movie third act trap
of we don't quite trust our emotional
story to have enough heft so we're going
to surround it in cg
i'm like i don't need two dragons
fighting like there's no one i'm here
for i'm here for a father and a son
all the cg
yeah like all i needed to do was see
father and son fight and the sun to
stand on his own two feet if you then
want the sun to take down a dragon okay
but he doesn't need to also ride a
dragon he's got 10 [ __ ] rings like
like make it david and goliath make it
[ __ ] beowulf and grendel make it this
massive like man versus monster thing
but it just got very swirly and colorful
and dynamic and
i got lost does he have 10 rings mark or
does he really have 10 bracelets
well they're big rings what is a
bracelet if not a ring extended good
point
um i did not uh i did find that i'm like
oh all right i guess i guess rings
olympic rings are pretty big
it's just like when i first saw like the
trailer and i was like oh it's not
rings
it's
rings it's the rings around his arms
armbands or whatever you know i was like
well
yeah i guess
rings can't do much and bands and then i
go back to this thing that a wise friend
once said to me about like you know ryan
johnson could have just given him an
x-wing
and i'm like they could have he could
have really just been rings he could
have been like and they were like cute
and they go through your eyes in the
back of your skull like the way i
understood his
wielding of the ten rings they
they were like extended arms right like
you could punch a guy way far away take
his [ __ ] head off or whatever the
[ __ ] and i'm sure each one maybe does
something different although that wasn't
very clear in the movie they just
seemed like they flung them a lot you
seem like very boomerang
in terms of like out they go and they
come back very yo-yo effect
but yeah i
you know i'm not it's not enough for me
to be like and that's why i didn't like
it but like
why couldn't it have been his brain
you know
i understand there was a lot of shang
chi they had to leave behind in order to
drag him into the 21st century but
you know like
nothing wrong with a [ __ ] deadly ring
like a man look at it
right back on your finger
you can take a kid away from the
official handbook of the marvel universe
but you can't take the official handbook
of the marvel universe true it's true
that was really it really got kind of
bumped into that as much as like wow
rings go on a finger those are bracelets
you know the group's not called the ten
bracelets or the ten arm dance
ten rings um
i liked uh aquafina i liked um the lead
what is his name
i liked him though on kim's convenience
so like i go
he's charming very very charming i
thought everybody did their jobs
insanely well i think you know they
spent all the right money and blah blah
blah um
you know i
i look i ain't criticizing because i
like the formula you know like i like
you know
peanut butter and jelly sandwich because
i know what i'm gonna get with a peanut
butter and jelly sandwich
but there's some you know stuff in in
this that felt like
oh that's wakanda oh that's
that's the magic cape except now it's a
dog with no head like oh that's the you
know
tropes or whatever that the familiar
things that they use in their origin
movies and stuff like that but
this was the first time i think i
noticed it more than i'd ever seen it in
other things like it really took
somebody smarter than me to be like
dr strange is iron man no it's not and
then i thought about i was like oh my
god it kind of is iron man all over
again and stuff not that it there's
anything wrong with that
very seinfeld not that there's anything
wrong with that
but yeah this is the first one that i
felt a little bit like oh that's from
that oh that's from that
yeah again i'm bitching i'm all for the
formula the formula [ __ ] works for me
but this is the first time i saw
the formula um but not because of like
nobody was
not doing their job well everybody was
at the very least executing if not
elevating but
there was a moment or two where i was
like
oh yeah no now i get it now i understand
what people mean when they're like come
on it's the same movie over and over i'm
like no it's not and this wasn't the
same movie over and over but there were
definitely
some familiar aspects which you're gonna
get when you do superhero origin even no
matter how groundbreaking it is like at
the end of the day there's some [ __ ]
that just
carries over you know now that you've
seen them the code of the matrix you
want to get that red pill that blue pill
like send me back under okay i don't
want to i don't want to see how we make
this i did i mean like i i felt like a
old man like when i watched the movie i
felt like 51 because i
like i normally i never see the strings
so to speak i'm like this [ __ ] puppet
show is astounding how do they get them
to dance like that
but uh this one i was like and again not
enough to pull me out of it but i was
like
oh that's from one of their other movies
oh that's from one of their other movies
but you know again source material same
[ __ ] thing you're talking about a
bunch of characters created by a bunch
of guys who
were like let's do this but this time
he's got this power he's just like this
but this time he's this
um i don't know if this happened before
or after and i know you got to go and
[ __ ] but
did you the rick and morty caesar season
opener that was submariner wasn't it um
i will take your word for it because i
have never seen rick and morty
[Laughter]
see it totally works yes um they did
what i assume
i can only assume is submariner it was
crazy [ __ ] close um but it was also
hysterical on that but i
i keep thinking about it um we gotta go
dune is coming kids dune is coming
dune is coming
[Music]
oh no no nerd large is going denny
villeneux agrees i did not say what
denny villeneux was saying at all i love
this [ __ ]
so if you're going to write an article
right how i [ __ ] like i love this
[ __ ] i think my favorite [ __ ]
american filmmaker
is kevin feige he's telling my favorite
story and [ __ ] over the course of many
movies so don't be hanging anything on
me where it's like he don't [ __ ] like
it no more i'm just saying
the dog with no head
reminded me of the of the doctor
strange's cape that's all
that's it yeah no i don't want to
[ __ ] poor denny villeneux man
i don't like these movies
not youtube
i
love these movies
honestly they're the happy place so
don't [ __ ]
try to paint it otherwise and you can't
have it both ways like i'm i'm the guy
you're usually going like hey [ __ ] on
the marvel payroll that [ __ ]
griffin
[ __ ] [ __ ] huckster shill whatever the
[ __ ] so
yeah if you're gonna choose anything
choose that i wish marvel would give me
money they don't disney disney money's
[ __ ] spends real nice
but if you're going to call me anything
call me a [ __ ] shill don't [ __ ]
say that i don't like this [ __ ] i legit
love this [ __ ]
like this is the [ __ ] that makes that
fuels my storytelling i don't use it
it's not like now i'm going to tell an
epic story i'm not gifted like that i'm
not a visual stylist but
you know
who
in the world you know kind of who
watches the watchmen kind of way who
entertains the entertainers
marvel entertains me
say nothing otherwise
that's legit how i feel and i'm even
trying to get a job like in fact if they
ever ask me i'd be like no way you want
to jump the shark
be my guest but i'm not going to be no
part of that you don't want i don't want
kevin smith in the marvel [ __ ]
pantheon and [ __ ] kevin smith belongs in
an audience watching the marvel movies
then coming here to fat man beyond to
tell you
how much he loves them
most of the time
all right we didn't even get to talk
about black widow which i've really
[ __ ] enjoyed did we talk about black
women i feel like we talked about black
widow maybe we did opening was [ __ ]
phenomenal yeah i feel like we did
um all right you gotta go jason we gotta
bounce everyone's gotta go this was just
a quick show kids uh to pop in and hi
we're back and uh we're doing it again
next tuesday if you wanna watch it
online
of course you're more than welcome and
[ __ ] but if you wanna come see us do it
live
tickets are on sale right now at
csmod.com or eventbrite.com
we'll have all the links
also
if you're into it uh schmodown is taping
at scum and villainy on saturday i think
there's still tickets to come and watch
that
and on sunday
uh sideshow collectibles is coming to
scum and villainy to do um
give
do trivia and give free stuff away
so some like really high-end
collectibles and stuff uh sunday night
with sideshow
dad i wish i had i want to plug my [ __ ]
sideshow is selling these bandai made
this
amazing
[ __ ] cue posca doll of me it's like a
little figurine
and it's got like these big eyes oh my
god i'm wearing the pink coat or the
purple cobra with the white hat all of
it's [ __ ] adorable and [ __ ] next show
i'll bring it with me so i could show
you also uh that book came out kevin
smith's secret stash it's over there
otherwise i'd pick it up and show you um
but my god it's [ __ ]
phenomenal it is packed
with pictures and stories and stories
i've never told before lots of pull outs
and [ __ ] like that um you can find it on
amazon.com or inside editions
they made it they make those thick-ass
coffee table books for like the delorean
and ghostbusters and [ __ ]
so it's out there right now it's the
perfect christmas gift for somebody who
that one person in your life who still
likes kevin smith
what do you got to sell where are you
going to send them
um i'm going to send them uh i'm going
to send them no place um instead i will
say
um there are lots of people who at the
moment could use a little bit of help
some of which live in new orleans some
of which are you know haitian refugees
who are being deported against their
will some of which are in texas looking
for access to uh to to health care in a
real equal way
go give some of that money to somebody
who could use it um and also buy kevin's
book
or don't this week thank you make me
feel like a total piece of [ __ ] but
yes mark's right perhaps save your 65
dollars for my very pricey book and give
it to a [ __ ] far more needy cause
i'll be fine but like make sure you get
the book sooner or later make sure
someone gives you the book as a
christmas gift even better yeah plant
seeds yeah yeah but he's right help
people that need some [ __ ] help kids
um all right there it is man we're back
we're back on the regular we're ready to
go beyond on a regular basis and stuff
uh
if you enjoyed these uh proceedings you
better thank uh jc banff man himself you
could thank him by going to to uh scum
and villainy cantina throwing back one
of them blue milks
next tuesday either he's still [ __ ]
chasing a child around that
next tuesday i'll be there
are you gonna be there oh for us that's
right are you gonna bring the kid give
him his first drink
probably not her first drink rather give
him some of that blue milk be like here
try to stand up and handle this kid
um all right kids there it is ben nice
to be back
always a pleasure always a damn pleasure
uh remember be kind to everybody
um you never know what they're going
through
and
if you're going to write an article
about tonight
do not write that i have a problem with
the marvel cinematic don't take away
from me
one of the only good things in my life
kids
i like these marvel movies i love them
resist the clickbait kids yeah come on
don't
it's one one title for all those
articles kev
sucks marvel's dick so hard we suspect
he's paid by them but why would they
they don't need the help like
look i would click on that [ __ ]
headline i'm like
there's a lot going on a lot to one it's
a bit long but it says the story
i guess i wouldn't click on it because
i'm like it's all right there in the
[ __ ] headline pretty amazing
uh there it is kids uh well i can't wait
to to do more of this uh next week and
anything we didn't touch i do feel like
we got to a lot of [ __ ] that people were
asking about and chat so anything we
didn't touch this week we'll hit on next
week for sure um
uh there ain't no show without the guy
sitting over there in the millennium
falcon kids give it up for marvelous
mark bernardin a movie star a movie star
who i've seen recently in a motion
picture who i gotta better get my agent
sirius screen time that's right that's
right he's gonna make st we're gonna
start talking about making that mark
bernard money never mind that robert
kirkford for sure bring me bring me your
standard rich and famous and silent
contract please
look you're following in good footsteps
i've made a whole [ __ ] career of not
talking in movies it worked out pretty
good oh i know i know there's a there's
a pattern for me to follow there's like
there's a rodent it's going to sound
creepy but i'm grooming you
for success mark
yes pretty soon i'm going to get in the
talkies
oh no we got a bunch of thumbs down by
aussie r why aussie r what did we
what did we do how could we not how
could we get so many thumbs down ozzy r
uh halloween kills trailer we didn't i
haven't seen it yet and we'll talk about
it next week sounds good kids we're
gonna go
uh thank you for being here uh for fat
man beyond i'm kevin smith and i am mark
bernard tune in next week same fat time
same
fat channel spodcast.com or youtube.com
kevin smith
uh
uh god what do we say at the end oh
jeff's kiss